so here's what I'm going to do which is
a little bit unusual and just comes out
of the fact that I realize I never used
the reference sheet as well as it could
have been I want you to write with me
everything that's under that middle
heading is not that much because we
actually know pretty much all of it now
the purpose of us writing it will be to
talk through what it means and also so
you know what there and what's not there
okay so let me get rid of this some this
function that we don't want to
differentiate and we're just going to go
step by step writing everything that's
there because basically I'm assuming
after two weeks
your brain is somewhat turned to mush so
let's unmask a fire that's the technical
term and get you back on the horse it
will help if you have two colors in one
color that's a bad choice in one color
will actually write the stuff that's on
the reference sheet and another color we
will annotate will talk about what's
going on okay so this is the very first
thing that you see at the top of that
section and immediately it should signal
to you some things are going on okay for
starters here's my first annotation what
kind of object is this this is a
parabola very good okay so the first
thing I'm going to say is I know what
this object is but it's a parabola
stated in a very particular form what
form would we call this what was the
what was the topic before we introduced
this idea of the parameter yeah it was
the lockers right so this is the
parabola in locus form we know that from
straight lines we can take the same
object like a straight line and provide
a lots of different forms based on what
we want to know about the form you could
go slope gradient or two-point or
whatever you want it okay in this fall
for a parabola what do we see for
example what's that guy this is the
focal length right now the focal length
doesn't mean anything until you remember
well when you talk about locus when you
talk about locus you mean you're
describing some kind of curve
some kind of function or not function
like a circle in terms of particular
geometric features what are the
geometric features that define what the
focal length is you could say this a
couple of different ways any suggestions
okay so I'm gonna carry on Russell's
definition I don't need some help to
refine this a little bit he talked about
a distance between and which is quite
clear I mean two lengths right so it's a
distance between two things he talked
about a point and a line but there's
specific points of specific lines that
we're talking about here right can
someone help us provide some more
information here yeah rid me okay
between the focus and what now think for
a moment think back okay so when you
think and maybe it might help you again
in your annotating Cullerton war a
little diagram over here when you think
about our regular parabola like so okay
the focus I guess we'd place that
somewhere up here if that's where the
focus is and I'm going to label it with
the characteristically unhelpful that
are s if that's what the focus is
where's the focal length on this diagram
it's it's I'm gonna need original color
now it's on its this distance isn't it
that's the focal length a so it's the
distance between the focus and though
what in the vertex right I could say the
parabola is the shortest distance but
it's more helpful from it's more
descriptive to say the particular place
where that happens has a name anyway so
I'm going to call it that and the vertex
if the distance between the focus and
the vertex which is also the shortest
distance between and there's this other
feature you telling me about right what
was the other feature the directrix it's
the shortest distance or I could have
said the perpendicular distance between
the directrix and the vertex
same length you can measure from two
sports and I guess I'll put that other
spot in now there's a the second version
right and you can see where the dirt
juice would be happy times okay right so
far so good yeah say that again
so this is just the name of the
coordinate a is the actual length yeah
so if that length of a then I can say
the coordinates of s would be well it's
on the y axis right so what will the x
corner be zero and its aid units upwards
so that would be zero comma a okay so
far so good we haven't even gotten off
the first line I should point out we
haven't said anything about this but
there's one more thing I want to state
which is this is the parabola a locus
form but it has to look like this it has
to pass through the origin how do I know
that it has to pass through the origin
how do I know yeah ah okay so this is
like the the standard lockers form the
simplest lockers form you could find
right another way of saying this is x
equals 0 then then this whole left-hand
side is 0 so Y clearly also has to be 0
you're passing through the origin so
this is the parabola in lockers form but
it can be translated as well how would I
translate it if I wanted to what would I
write differently about this equation
yeah ok
so yeah you got the right idea so this
is the same this is the same thing it's
still the parabola it's still in lockers
full but I've just moved it somewhere
else now please note I said to you
before one of the things you've got to
know about the reference a is what's on
it but also what's not on it okay why do
we not provide this to you because you
should be able to work that out from the
original thing you know how to move
things around here and there same idea
just put in another place H comma okay
what is this the units of H comma K -
this parabola it
that it's the vertex isn't it okay
that's why I was highlighting the origin
before okay thank goodness that was a
lot of annotation for one two three four
five six seven eight nine characters so
let's keep going
the next thing it says is this x equals
to 80 y equals a T squared hmm what's
this this has a name this pair of
objects what are these things called
yeah these are the parametric equations
right which immediately tells you once
you describe these things are the
parametric equations that actually tells
you we've missed something from the
earlier thing what is this thing if
these are the parametric equations
what's this thing called
it's the Cartesian equation there's no
parameter there's no T in sight in the
original equation so this guy is the
Cartesian equation singular I hope this
is serving two recent bells in your head
this is this is the intent of doing this
okay so these parametric equations what
they tell you is that the parameter T is
this third variable it's this third
variable it's on the side that's little
literally what parameter means this is
on the side measurement and it defines x
and y if you know what T is you can find
out what x and y are independently okay
in the context of the parabola what is
the parameter what does it actually mean
because on the unit circle we know at
that parameter theta means it's the
angle at the center
what is this programing in the context
of the parabola it's the gradient at
that point
okay